ils ont été élus il y a quasiment huit
mois jour pour jour les 569 députés que
compte l'Assemblée nationale avait alors
deux mois pour déclarer leur situation
patrimoniale et bien immobilier
véhicules assurance vie ou action
détenue il ne devait rien cacher à la
Haute autorité pour la transparence de
la vie publique cette institution
indépendante vient de rendre public une
partie de leur déclaration Florent
Clavel a analysé celle des cinq députés
élus pour l'Indre-et-Loire
on Indre-et-Loire des députés aux
revenus confortables voire très
confortable c'est le Caden real Fondary
fils du fondateur d'un groupe de
cliniques privées le groupe Saint-Gatien
l'élu du parti horizon d'Edouard
Philippe aperçu l'an dernier plus de
160000 euros de rémunération au titre de
ces différentes participations dans des
établissements de santé ou société
civile immobilière à ses revenus
s'ajoutent son indemnité parlementaire
de 5800 euros et celle de conseiller
départemental 1200 euros par mois
en deuxième position la députée Sabine
Tillet en plus de son indemnité
parlementaire les lieux modem perçoit
9000 euros de loyer annuel via une SCI
ainsi que 1200 euros de dividendes grâce
à des actions dans une dizaine de
banques ou multinationales comme Total
énergie Sanofi ou encore Schneider
Electric
l'écologie se charge Fournier perd soit
son indemnité parlementaire à laquelle
peuvent s'ajouter des missions
ponctuelles de formation son métier
initial pour l'élu de Tours la
déclaration d'activités et d'intérêt est
une nécessité démocratique ce n'est pas
mis à jour ça finit par se savoir
aujourd'hui donc du coup là on prend le
risque du doute là c'est déclaré c'est
clair voilà c'est connu de tout le monde
enfin Fabienne callboc et Daniel la
baronne ne perçoivent que leur indemnité
parlementaire de 5800 euros quant au
patrimoine des élus notamment immobilier
il reste sous bonne garde la déclaration
est consultable en préfecture mais
interdite à la diffusion sous peine de
fortes